let's truck they ever your best shark
day I've got good ones how far offshore
is this about 50 miles
okay San Diego of San Diego yeah that's
in California that's how you find a lot
of Makos and blues I mean it's a
magnificent that thing is sure look at
the shape of his body and his tail it's
almost like geese on he's not real
ya know it looks like such aa it's such
a design such a cool-looking yeah fish
amazing and that's just a little one
there right yeah I'm gonna hang catch
that one and then I'm gonna catch a big
one that segment I I ride I ride one I
hand feed blues it was six Makos and
three blues showed up that day at first
they were chasing each other off the big
ones are running off the small ones and
then later on they got comfortable each
other and then they started hanging out
this is the big that's the little ones -
look at its eyes how big they are
yeah vision now bigger Makos will lead
the Blues and and the baby Makos also
really cannibalize their own kind yeah
it's one of the few animals that
actually eat each other right like
there's not many prêt like Gators dude
Gators eat other Gators yeah that scene
when they showed it over again that's
when I was ready to catch him I was
gonna catch up Michael what about the
Gators I was gonna say like sharks are
one of the few predators that
cannibalize each other is that right or
do a lot of them Gators do it Gators do
it - Lions do it bears do it oh [ __ ]
that thing's like a little torpedo it
can jump 20 feet in the air is world's
fastest shark yeah it's warm-blooded -
its
the ability to warm his blood of it is
warm it's not cold blood like the other
sharks it's the only shark that's like
that no I think the other members of his
family might be like that to the great
white may have that a bit of oh yeah
there's five mackerel shark members
mackerel shark members yeah which is
ellagic likely well the family is great
white shortfin mako
longfin Mako and porbeagle hmm oh my god
so you just caught salmon in the salmon
shark remember yeah I just caught it
yeah look at this thing
that's sand fishing you noodled a mako
well you can't you can't kill him
through his mouth you cut your hand off
oh I gotta grab his body no he's not a
slippery is you got gloves on his skin
feels it's like almost like sandpaper so
I get a grip on it
which is nice but yeah you gotta grab
it's nice yeah you gotta grab him like
that because that guy right there will
knock your fingers right off she's you
know you yeah you don't want him to bite
you he can kill you I release something
he stayed with us the rest of the day
even though they caught him you didn't
care there's a blue that's a blue that's
a scary [ __ ] shark right there well
they're all scary about dill if you
offer him your hand it'll bite it off
you he'll bite it he'll take it if you
let him bite you he will bite you you
can't let him bite you well these suits
your where they kind of like bite-proof
a little bit and stuff or no no they're
just regular wetsuits special when
you're surfing you know yeah yeah yes I
butter see I'm writing that one oh my
god I can't lie that would probably be a
super cool feeling right there to ride a
shark but I'm still dependent I mean you
go ahead and catch a ride yeah yeah that
would be cool yeah you were saying they
sound if you grab on to them they'll
sound oh yeah yeah but you still get
right yes okay no you hold your breath
you let go when you think it's time to
go keep going with you if you overdo it
you make you may come back at you really
yeah yeah have you put on a tank and
stayed on a mono
yeah he eventually got mad and say no
Fidel 'funny was turn around and you
know when you catch one yeah that could
have been a disaster there you get
tangled in that rope and so could have
been disaster there I almost got bit by
blue that day Robin almost got bit by
blue that day - producer is this amico
yeah that's freaking terrifying see you
didn't take the bait I think this is the
one I'm gonna I'm gonna catch him no I
think this is the one yeah yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna hang catch this one how
big is this one he's pretty big watch
see I got him already
oh my oh my what yeah I told the guys if
I hang catch a Mako he's gonna drag no
lotion and he's gonna because I'm tilt
to one side he's gonna end up right back
where by the boat again right so he's
gonna take that huge circle quit that
went chasing me but I said about book
you're gonna catch him you're gonna
catch him coming right to you Robin was
there waiting for me I don't know see
there's Robin over the camera at the
boat you still got this thing now see
now again we got if I've wanted to keep
them I would've told guys get a rope and
just put a rope around his tail on some
boat on you know we're we're neck we're
not getting meat we're getting video
right right some people want you to
release the shark some people don't at
this time I'm there you know we're
entertaining the public I'm building my
personal challenge right but I'm doing
ceiling look at the size of this one
[ __ ] this one here I'm gonna I'm gonna I
try to put him in roll him on his back
yeah and I gotta write them backwards I
lifted it out of water I'm gonna flip
him you can go in a tonic immobility but
I did flip on table stuff to produce a
rope for me to say you know oh really
when I'm not there talking it's me
talking in there yeah maybe some stuff
and any right stuff in there which is
okay you know it's the people going
right now I'm gonna tell you what's
going right what do you think might be a
right as a catcher right now is there
any shark that you can't and cannot eat
cannot eat like cannot like this not
good to eat the Greenland shark you have
to boil it they say in order to to eat
it because it's poisonous where you boil
the heck out of it you can eat it as
people up there eat it okay it's a weird
Greenland shark England shark gets cold
cold cold water shark but overall I mean
you can eat a hammerhead it tastes like
lousy you can eat a bull shark I've
eaten it it tastes terrible really
almost got me there
here's know here's what happened
something no no is the old one see you
I'm gonna flip them now okay that's a
big make clear this is where he's like
paralyzed when you put your dancing
sharks wow it's a lot of fun
Manny you're a psycho can you do that
stuff with dolphins I seem like a lot
nice no you don't you don't dolphins in
captivity or mean smart and mean exact
it's just like killer whales they end up
killing somebody